Trump gives a triumphant State of the
Union address Nancy Pelosi breaches
protocol and Democrats continue to panic
over their 2020 candidates I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
stop putting your online data at risk
get protected at expressvpn comm slash
Ben that's Express VPN comm slash man
now you may have noticed that we are
like one month into the year and it's
sheer chaos out there cats and dogs
living together the end of the world
we've watched near conflict in the
Middle East we have watched an
impeachment effort go down the tubes
we've watched everybody worried about
coronavirus wouldn't it be a good time
to diversify your investments just a
little bit into precious metals like
wouldn't that be a smart thing to do
I mean global instability particularly
in places like China can actually impact
currency trading on a pretty significant
level and we're also blowing out the
debt and the deficit which means that at
a certain point the bill is gonna come
due I'm not saying take all your money
and put it in gold and bury it in the
backyard I'm saying take some of your
money and diversify it into precious
metals you can do that with my friends
over at Birch gold if you haven't yet
taken the first step of requesting a
free information kit on gold go ahead
and do it if you haven't converted a
portion of your eligible IRA or 401k to
an IRA and precious metals have the
conversation ask all of your questions
get more information about it Birch gold
will go to work and make things super
simple for you I trust them and working
with them for years wouldn't recommend
them if I didn't trust them there's no
obligation you have nothing to lose to
take that first step
Birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau text Ben - 47 47 47
during the month of January when you
open an IRA and precious metals you will
get a signed copy of my book the right
side of history for free
again you have to text Ben - 47 47 47
open an IRA in precious metals get a
signed copy of my book the right side of
history again text Ben - 47 47 47 and
when you do open that IRA and precious
metals you get a signed copy of my book
the right side of history also even if
you don't want to open that IRA you
should be looking into diversification
it's a smart thing to do ok so last
night last night was a night a president
Trump has had himself quite a week very
big week for the President of the United
States and last night the Democrats blew
it in a massive massive way they really
did let me just explain what the
Democrats week has gone like because
Trump is just too
side of that right if then I'm going to
have a bad week that means that Trump
had a pretty good week so here is what
the Democrats have done over the last
week over the last week alone it's been
a crap week for them
I mean seriously so first there is the
Democrats bump in Iowa remember that was
gonna happen don't get big publicity
Democrats bump in Iowa remember that
yeah then there's the Democrats
impeachment effort remember how that was
going to go great for them they're gonna
impeach the President of the United
States you remember that and who's gonna
give him a big bump because everyone was
going to see how corrupt Trump was well
today they're taking that final
impeachment vote in the Senate the vote
to convict yeah yeah and then the
Democrats were making the case that
listen even if you like the economy even
if you like things that are going on in
foreign policy the president of the
United States the petty trial do you
petty tyrannical child it's all chaos
inside the White House we are the adults
in the room right that's what we are
worthy adults in the room and you can
trust us with power because number one
we know how to handle things not like
the Iowa caucuses or anything and also
we are not going to be Petty and
mean-spirited and ridiculous we're not
going to act like small children in any
way so the Democrats looking like adults
right that was gonna be there their
campaign was that they were gonna
restore honor and dignity and decency to
the White House and then last night they
just and you know what all that adds up
to you know what all that adds up to the
Democrats 2020 chances you know I've
been fairly bearish on the front chances
for reelection until 2020 right I I said
I'd put him in know better than 5050 if
Donald Trump of last night shows up not
only is he gonna win he's gonna win big
now obviously you we say this after
every Donald Trump State of the Union
address which is today is the moment
Trump finally arrived but the reality is
that Trump is at his strongest point of
his presidency he's at 49% in the Gallup
poll approval rating which is his
highest point of his presidency 63% of
Americans say that they like the economy
and they like how president from handles
the economy more importantly and
Democrats are looking Wilder more
radical more ridiculous more petty more
thin-skinned more childish every single
day so you know last night you know it
looked like it looked like this is what
they are doing with their 20/20 chances
the Democrats 2020 chances
it's a real bad week for Democrats a
real bad week for Democrats so president
Trump strolls on into the Congress last
night he is still under impeachment
theoretically because today is the day
that they're gonna finish this whole
thing they're gonna be no more than
forty eight votes presumably before the
actual conviction of the president here
so they didn't get a single Republican
vote anywhere along the line and this
whole thing started with Nancy Pelosi
being awful so that people were ripping
on Trump because supposedly Trump
snubbed her handshake will analyze that
in one second because listen first of
all I wouldn't put it past from snubber
handshake second of all I'm not sure
that I'd blame from snubbing her
handshake after what she does here right
people want to pretend that Donald Trump
is the only petty vengeful thin-skinned
man in Washington DC I'd like to welcome
you to Congress I'd like to welcome you
to American politics where people are
vengeful and petty and idiotic and
thin-skinned like if you spend any time
on the hill you'll recognize one of the
great disappointments in life Adam
Carolla used to say this the godfather
of podcasting Adam Carolla used to say
this used to say one of the great
disappointments in life is that when
you're a kid and you sit around you look
at all the adults they'll have cars
they'll have houses
they'll have spouses and you think to
yourself man the adults are really smart
man they they must know things and then
you grow up and you become an adult and
all the people that you were in class
with who are picking their boogers and
sticking them under the desk all those
kids are adults and they're morons okay
this is the great disappointment of
American politics if you're somebody who
is deeply invested in American politics
it turns out that politicians are just
like all other human beings namely they
are venal and they are stupid and they
are idiotic and they're thin-skinned and
they are childish and Nancy Pelosi is no
exception
Queen slaying it turns out she is just
as ridiculous and petty and vengeful as
the man that all the left loves to hate
right they've got the orange man bad
he's a child and all of this stuff and
is president from thin-skinned of course
of course I mean if you want the news
the President Trump is the most
dignified president to ever attend her
the office they're gonna have to go
somewhere else because that ain't true
but I'll tell you something Nancy Pelosi
is nowhere near dignified she has
nowhere near decent Nancy Pelosi is
terrible so this thing opens right that
what starts the controversy truly starts
the controversy is the fact that Nancy
Pelosi in announcing the President of
the United States doesn't use the
traditional honor
so traditionally the Speaker of the
House says it is my great honor and and
great and duty is that there's like an
actual formula that you use when you are
the Speaker of the House instead she
just says here's the president right
she's kind of drops here's the president
they say here she is saying that
yesterday members of Congress the
President of the United States right so
she she doesn't bother with the
traditional honorific okay now what the
left was all upset about is Trump
supposedly snubbing or handshake now the
the actual quote-unquote snub it's
unclear whether this actually happened
well you'll watch the whole thing I want
to do this like this is a brooder film
but I think that it's important to
actually know what happened here so
you'll see that Trump hands copies of
his speeches to the copies of the speech
will come in handy later he handsome
depends he hands them to Pelosi and then
he doesn't shake Pence's hand and then
he's already turning away by the time
she offers her hand to shake and he sort
of turns away first of all she's
impeaching him so frankly I don't care
you know I know people get very upset
about this sort of thing
oh it's so terrible so that I don't
think it's that terrible that she didn't
use the honorific except that it's more
traditional I don't think that it's that
terrible that he didn't shake her hand
oh yeah I actually prefer honesty and
politics to all of the pomp and ceremony
I think that the State of the Union
address is a bag of crap usually but I
will just point out that Nancy Pelosi is
a vengeful vengeful human being and all
of it remember that time that Nancy
Pelosi was asked specifically about
whether she hated Donald Trump you
remember this she was asked about
whether she hated Donald Trump and she
got very angry to put her I don't hate
down a Trump I'm a Catholic how dare you
sure sure you know okay so then the
speech that was the opener so at the
opener you already know that the the gap
is very wide and then Trump recedes to
give what is one of the two best
features of his presidency the other
great speech of his presidency was the
speech that he gave over in Europe where
he talked about defense in Western
civilization less hated that one to his
speech last night by the by the
immediate poll numbers was approved by
some seventy six percent of Americans
including eighty two percent of
independents has a very very good speech
it was well written was well organized
President Trump does the thing that all
presidents do since Reagan you know the
thing where you shout out somebody in
the top row of the of the back of the of
the Congress and you honor them and it's
like the price is right you come on
the president have been doing this since
Reagan started this tradition back in
the 80s and usually it's really boring
and and kind of forced Trump does this
amazingly well because president from is
a TV guy right president Trump
understands how TV works and so he
showed instead of telling I'm president
Trump picks great guests and then he
does cool and fun things that's okay
you're allowed to do cool and fun things
during the State of the Union address
but we're gonna get into all the details
of the State of the Union address
because if this is his real Lex campaign
he's gonna whomp whoever the Democrats
put up it ain't gonna matter
it could be Sanders could be Biden won't
matter right if this Trump showed up if
this truck showed up full time this got
to be at 55% in the approval ratings and
this thing would be over with this
economy with this foreign policy this
thing would be over it would be done
well get to more on this in just one
second first it would be a foolish move
for you to park out on the streets of
Los Angeles
and not lock your car door when we have
a lot of petty crime here in the city of
Los Angeles it would be a foolish move
not to lock your front door at night no
matter where you live because even
though the chances are very low that
somebody's gonna break into your house
those chances exist well then why are
you leaving your internet activity
unlocked there's a significantly better
shot that somebody is gonna grab your
internet data then that somebody's gonna
break into your house but you don't
leave your front door unlocks oh don't
leave your internet activity unprotected
either there are a lot of people looking
for that internet activity you got big
data or trying to grab it and use it and
monetize it you got the government
trying to monitor you you also have the
the hackers who are constantly looking
for those credit card numbers so they
can make money off of you this is why I
use Express at VPN it's the software
that I and thousands of my fans use
every day to protect our data online in
the time since I started using
expressvpn hacking methods have grown
more sophisticated at the Daily wire we
invest thousands of dollars a month in
cyber security because we are a regular
target of attacks but you don't have to
spend that kind of money to get great
protection instead go check out Express
at VPN and do it yourself visit my
special link right now expressvpn comm
slash Ben get an extra three months of
expressvpn for free protect your
internet today with the VPN I trust to
keep my data safe go to expressvpn comm
slash ben's get started again that's
expressed at VPN comm slash Ben to get
started okay so we're gonna get into the
content from speech a note Donald Trump
was so good last night
okay this was like it I've had good
Trump bad Trump right we had a jingle we
played it for years
hey this was excellent from this is like
top-notch peak Trump in his element
right speaking in front of a crowd yes
speaking off teleprompter it is no sin
to speak off the teleprompter the speech
was well written it was well organized
as I keep saying and he also is great at
pointing out particular Americans who
are unifying in in who they are right
that it was just wonderful all of this
means that if this Trump showed up if he
showed up full time just imagine for a
second just in your mind's eye imagine
this Trump instead of the Trump who sits
in toilet rage tweets imagine Riley he's
sitting in the bathroom just in mini
mega Blin but instead of that imagine
you got this every day if you got this
every day Donald Trump would be Ronald
Reagan if he got this every day Donald
Trump would be Ronald Reagan and he'd be
winning Reagan leg victories which means
there's good news and there's bad news
the good news is that this is that Trump
speak is pretty hot right that he's got
a lot of room to grow if he became this
right I know this is it's like falling
on deaf ears it's so irritating but if
he were this all the time he'd be almost
unstoppable if Donald Trump is not this
and he loses that's on no one except
Donald Trump because if you have the
potential to hit 350 in the major
leagues and instead you decide to go out
partying every night and show up drunk
the next morning and then bat with a
hangover and you end up batting 260 that
is not on your batting coach that is not
on the opposing pitchers that is on you
so this means that Trump bears the heavy
load of responsibility of being best
Trump okay the Trump that we saw last
night Republicans conservatives I think
Americans all Americans regardless of
your political orientation would like to
see every day and if you were like this
not only his positions but he himself
would be personally more popular why
because what we saw last night was
really peak stuff it was excellent
okay so Trump begins his speech and he
begins with the theme the theme is the
great American comeback and this is
indeed the theme of his presidency is
that like Ronald Reagan he's brought
America back from the brink that under
Barack Obama the economy had been
growing but an extraordinarily slow rate
that under Barack Obama America was less
respected around the world and who cares
about respect America was less powerful
around the world America was was less
muscular around the world and that the
American people were less confident in
themselves that they had lost faith in
their bill in the ability of the country
- to stand for good things and so Trump
says listen I'm here for the great
American comeback and my economic record
proves it and he spends the first like
twenty five minutes of the speech just
listing off economic stats which is
great it is it is smart politics it is
true and if all he did was tweet one
sentence from this speech every day from
now until the election if that's all he
tweeted he would win reelection because
this is his main pitch right his pitch
in 2016 was Hillary Clinton's the worst
she's terrible and and that was enough
to get him through but now that you're
president you got a run on your record
the good news for Trump is the guy's got
a great record or if you've looked at
just his accomplishments and not all the
crap that he says all the time this is
what and this is what conservatives and
Republicans would have Americans do
right you whenever you talk to
conservatives and Republicans they're
always like yeah we know what he is we
don't like the tweeds but look what he's
doing you'll hear that from nearly every
Republican okay well if Trump stopped
doing all the silly stuff and instead
did this and that's all you would get
right you would just get the good record
so here was president from talking about
the great American comeback three years
ago we launched the great American
comeback tonight I stand before you to
share the incredible results jobs are
booming incomes are soaring poverty is
plummeting crime is falling confidence
is surging and our country is thriving
and highly respected again America's
enemies are on the run
America's fortunes are on the rise in
America's future is blazing bright okay
and that's true okay the economy is on
the rise our fortunes are on the rise
internationally this in in terms of
policy this has been a very very good
presidency on everything except spending
this has been a very very good
presidency and then Trump continues to
pump the economy which again is the
point where he should be putting
pressure presidents or incumbent with
strong economies do not lose re-election
here as president from pushing on that
button the years of economic decay are
over the days of our country being used
taken advantage of and even scorned by
other nations are long behind
does God you are the broken promises
jobless recoveries tired platitudes and
constant excuses for the depletion of
American wealth power and prestige okay
that's a Reaganesque line I know wrote
the speech but this is excellent the
reason that that's excellent is because
that characterization of the Obama
administration which is what it is right
the jobless recovery the tired
platitudes which is what Obama was full
of open drank and the constant excuses
for why America couldn't be greater than
this right that that's good stuff that
is that is Ronald Reagan basically
saying to Jimmy Carter the days of
malaise are done excellent stuff from
President Trump excellent stuff from
from his speech writers and then
President Trump again pushes on this
button and this was the constant push
right this was the smartest part of the
speech the first 25 minutes as I say of
the speech or completely unifying
because most Americans are seeing their
wages rise
most Americans are seeing the best
economy that we have had in half a
century
most Americans are feeling very positive
about the trajectory of the economy so
why the hell wouldn't you brag about
that here is Trump continuing along
these lines in just three short years we
have shattered the mentality of American
decline and we have rejected the
downsizing of Americans destiny we have
totally rejected the downsizing we're
moving forward at a pace that was
unimaginable just a short time ago and
we are never ever going back means so
again this this is the strongest point
for president Trump and he continues to
push us now one of the things that this
does by pushing on the economy and
pushing on it hard for 25 minutes is
there a bunch of cutaways during this
part of the State of the Union and
Democrats would not stand for any of it
it would stand for any of it now I'll be
honest with you I don't remember during
Obama's State of the Union address when
he would talk about the economic
recovery and jobless rates being down
when the Republicans stood or not all I
know is that this doesn't look great
when Trump spent 20 minutes talking
about african-american jobless rate
those hits have been teenage jobless
rate lowest it's ever been Latino
travelers rate lowest it's ever been
female travelers rate lowest it's ever
been and all of them are sitting there
like
hmm bad look bad look wait a certain
point you might want to share good news
for the country sure it's good news for
Trump it's also good news for the
country I didn't it and sitting there
and acting as though it's bad news for
the country when good things are
happening does look pretty divisive now
a Democrats say is that the divisions in
our country aren't really about the
performance of the country on the
economy or anything like that the
divisions are purely about Trump which
is why what Trump did last night in
giving what was a well-spoken dignified
address to the American people
completely undercuts the Democrats
argument and when they act like children
it really undercuts their argument
because if their argument is the only
diss unifying part of the American
experiment right now is Donald Trump and
then Trump gets up there and gives a
unifying speech and acts like an adult
and they act like damn children that's a
horrible pitch it's a horrible pitch
it's bad politics to the max really bad
politics for the Democrats we'll get
some more of president Trump's barn
burner of a State of the Union address
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that going to the post
office that is a waste of productive
time you may love the post office that's
fine but you know taking all the boxes
schlepping them in the car going to the
post office waiting in line it takes a
lot of time out of your day and if
you're are in business time is money not
only that why would you spend the max
that you can on postage as opposed to
the minimum that you can on postage this
is where my friends at stamps calm comes
in postage rates have gone up again but
stamps calm eases the pain with big
discounts off post office retail rates
stamps calm brings all the services of
US Postal Service directly to your
computer whether you're a small office
sending invoices and online sellers
shipping out products even a warehouse
handing thousands of packages a day
stamps calm can handle all of this with
ease you simply use your computer to
print official US postage 24/7 for any
letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready just hand it to your mail
carrier or drop it in a mailbox it's
that simple
stamps calm not only saves you time it
saves you money as well with stamps calm
you get discounts and postage rates you
can't even get at the post office it's
no wonder 700,000 small business is
already use stamps calm there's no
excuse to go to the post office when
stamps calm is available we here at the
Daily wire use stamps calm for a good
reason
right now my listeners get a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and digital scale
without any long-term commitment just go
to stamps calm click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage
type in Shapiro that is Stan's comm
enter Shapiro and you get that special
deal it is a pretty great deal stamps
comm click on that mic at the top of the
homepage type in Shapiro
okay so President Trump goes on he brags
about the economy he talks about that
since its election we've created 7
million new jobs five million more than
the government experts projected during
the previous administration he talks
about the low unemployment rate he talks
about the net worth of bottom half of
wage earners increasing by forty seven
percent three times faster than the
increase for the top one percent of
means this whole litany of good news and
the Democrats will not stand up not only
will they not stand up they're really
upset about it and they grow
increasingly upset as the speech goes on
now Trump leads with all the most
unifying stuff right all the most
unifying stuff is here's the good news
for the country and the Democrats cannot
stand it horrible look for them because
then by the time that Trump gets to his
actual policy proposals many of which
are very controversial by the time he
gets to that and Democrats are walking
out first of all not all Americans are
watching by that point
second of all the Democrats wouldn't
stand for even the good thing so why do
we care that they're walking out for the
stuff they don't like that they actively
dislike if you won't stand up so you
have no credibility if you want to have
credibility if you're a Democrat and you
want to have credibility to say that
what Trump just said is so awful then
I'm really upset about it you can't sit
down while he says the good part if to
stand up for the good part and then when
he says the bad part then you walk out
or just as a matter of optics but
Democrats don't understand optics
apparently so instead they sit down for
all the good news so example here's
president from this clip six here's
President Trump talking about that net
worth of bottom half of wage earners
which is the best news for president
Trump right is that the Democrats keep
complaining that all of the growth is
going to the people at the top and that
is not true an enormous amount of growth
is going to the people at the lower end
of the economic spectrum because as it
turns out capitalism is a fantastic
engine here's President Trump since my
election the net worth of the bottom
half of wage earners has increased by 47
percent three times faster than the
increase for the top one percent after
decades of flat and falling incomes
wages are rising fast and wonderfully
they are rising fastest for low-income
workers who have seen a 16 percent pay
increase since my election the
is a blue-collar boom real median
household income is now at the highest
level ever recorded okay this all great
news and the Democrats are sitting there
sucking lemons I mean every lemon in the
grove
it's amazing they've somehow turned
lemonade into lemons and they're sucking
on those lemons and they are sour-faced
and they are angry and they are upset
right and and then President Trump moved
into the more controversial parts of
speech now what was great about the
speech many things great about the
speech one of the things that was great
about this speech was that President
Trump did as I say he front-loaded all
the unifying stuff and Democrats refused
to even cheer for their own unification
and then he moved into subtle critiques
of the Democrats via popular policies
which is excellent excellent politics so
he right before he gets into all the
controversial parts he talked about
criminal justice reform a policy I don't
like by the way I think criminal justice
reform is based on the basic lie that
there's mass incarceration in the
country based on race that the police
are going and rounding up black and
brown people for no reason and that this
is just the repeal of the of the
Thirteenth Amendment in effect and all
of it I don't believe any of that I
think it's mythical I think people who
commit crimes should go to jail and I
think that releasing people early from
prison who go to jail typically has a
pretty steep downside in terms of the
recidivism rate and we've seen that here
in the state of California but that is
one of trumps bipartisan his bipartisan
bills the criminal justice reform passed
by Democrats what was amazing about this
is even when Trump announced criminal
justice reform and talked about it in
the State of the Union address Democrats
still had a rough time clapping for it
so Nancy Pelosi was like slow to get to
her feet on criminal justice reform for
example but here was President Trump
finishing up the sort of unifying
portion of his features of the first 35
minutes is clip 7 our roaring economy
has for the first time ever given many
former prisoners the ability to get a
great job and a fresh start the second
chance at life is made possible because
as we passed landmark criminal justice
reform into law everybody said that
criminal justice reform couldn't be done
but I got it done and the people in this
room got it done
ok and the Democrats see their even see
pence in the background clapping and
Pelosi refuses to clap for a bill that
she helped sponsor right look you can
see pence starts without now
actually she realizes what's going on
and if she was distracted or what
eventually she realizes what's going on
and that she's not supposed to be sour
for this part and she starts clapping
that is a bad optic look he is
complimenting the people in the room and
the Democrats are like won't take the
compliment from said a nice thing can't
do that okay then
Trump got into the subtle critique of
the Democrats in this part truly whoever
structured this speech it's quite
brilliant because the way that he
criticizes the Democrats is by not
criticizing the Democrats directly at
least during this portion of the speech
as the speech goes on he gets harsher
and harsher and his criticism of the
Democrats so he begins by pointing out
that he has brought to the room Quon
Cueto who's legitimate leader of
Venezuela who has been barred from the
from the leadership of Venezuela by the
socialist dictator Nicolas Maduro in
critic in critiquing Maduro Trump is
subtly critiquing all the Democrats who
have refused to side with white oh that
would include people like Ella Hahn Omar
and Bernie Sanders people who have
suggested that Maduro should remain in
power or that majora isn't a dictator or
any of that kind of stuff because at
root they are socialists so here's
President Trump pointing out on white oh
in the audience again Trump is fantastic
at the game show aspect of the State of
the Union right the power he says okay
this person up in the rafters and
everybody cheers or we've seen this
before where he brought in the refugee
from North Korea who brought his
crutches I mean he's great at picking
guests for the State of the Union many
other presidents have not been I
remember when George W Bush brought the
lady who I founded Baby Einstein or
something like Trump is great at this
because he's a TV guy he understands how
TV works so here he is paying tribute to
Quon Widow the United States is leading
a 59 Nation diplomatic coalition against
the socialist dictator of venezuela
nicolas maduro a tyrant who brutalizes
his people but medoras Gripen tyranny
will be smashed and broken here this
evening it's a very brave man who
carries with him the hopes dreams and
aspirations of all Venezuelans joining
us in the gallery is the true and
legitimate president of Venezuela
Juan Guido
the president please take this message
back here
please take this message back that all
Americans are united with the Venezuelan
people in their righteous struggle for
freedom socialism destroys nations but
always remember freedom unifies the soul
okay the fact that the Trump is now
contrasting socialism in Venezuela with
freedom right that is a message to the
Democrats because guess who their
frontrunner is right now a self-declared
socialist a self-declared socialist who
skipped this State of the Union address
to go rally in New Hampshire his base
where he's gonna talk about the glories
of socialism which by the way has about
a 19 percent approval rating among
Americans so that's that smart
politicking by the president then again
he's great at this he brought forth
Charles Magee so he talks about how this
young 13 year old whose name is Ian
wants to join space force which by the
way all four space force man space force
is fantastic first thing we need to
build the Deathstar but she calls out
Charles Magee Charles McGee is a
Tuskegee Airmen now I've had Tuskegee
Airmen on the radio show amazing
unbelievable people and not only a
tribute to America but a tribute to
black Americans in particular who went
and fought for a country that was
discriminative ly discriminating against
them but recognizing that even as they
were fighting for the country that was
actively discriminating against them
that the promises of the Declaration and
the Constitution would eventually be
upheld and justified and that America
was and is a great force for good in the
world
right the fact that that the Tuskegee
Airmen were willing to fight for America
and Colin Kapernick today isn't willing
to not kneel for the national anthem is
in fact a repudiation of a lot of the
race-based politics that are happening
right now because let me tell you if
black Americans in 1943 were willing to
go and shoot down Nazi fighters over
Berlin at a time when they came back to
the United States where immediately
shoveled into segregation what does that
say about the lack of gratitude respect
and courage of people like Colin
Kaepernick and that's that's what a
large part of this is about as you'll
see here's President Trump calling out
Charles Magee now this is reported by
Ben Jacob so I believe is a reporter at
NBC News Ben Jacobs reported that Ilhan
Omar and Rashidah Talib did not even
stand for Charles Magee which is
unbelievable if that's true again that's
not me reporting that's Ben Jacobs
reporting that here is president Trump
calling out Charles
Charles McGee was born in Cleveland Ohio
one century ago Charles is one of the
last surviving Tuskegee Airmen the first
black fighter pilots and he also happens
to be Ian's great-grandfather after more
than 130 combat missions in World War
two he came back home to a country still
struggling for civil rights
and went on to serve America in Korea
and Vietnam on December 7th Charles
celebrated his 100th birthday a few
weeks ago assigned to bill
promoting Charles McGee to Brigadier
General and earlier today I pinned the
stars on his shoulders in the Oval
Office General McGee our nation salutes
you thank you sir yeah I mean that's
awesome stuff right that's just that's
super cool it is it is fantastic it also
leads Trump into a little a little bit
of the speech where he talks about the
history of the United States and he kind
of subtly bashes Congress from teaching
him he never mentioned impeachment the
homelite this was his only subtle
reference to impeachment and it again a
smart reference here because if you're
not watching you're not gonna catch it
here is Trump mentioning to Congress
guys you know what we've had priorities
before in those priorities don't
generally include impeaching people for
non impeachable conduct from the
pilgrims to the founders from the
soldiers at Valley Forge to the marchers
at Selma and from President Lincoln to
the Reverend Martin Luther King
Americans have always rejected limits on
our children's future members of
Congress we must never forget that the
only victories that matter in Washington
are victories that deliver for the
American people the people are the heart
of our country their dreams are the soul
of our country and their love is what
powers and sustains our country we must
always remember that our job is to put
America first taken smart politics
because the converse would be don't put
America first and also when he says the
only victories that
worth winning are the ones that win for
the people of the country he's basically
saying it's not a political victory to
impeach people on the basis of nonsense
right that that's that is the underlying
tone there right that is the reference
again when you get to more from
president Trump's quite brilliant State
of the Union address he goes hard after
the Democrats in just second and we'll
get to Nancy Pelosi's insane display I
mean really like politically insane I
don't mean like she's an actual crazy
person she's gonna run through the
streets flinging poo or something that's
just her constituents in San Francisco I
mean that she is I just mean that she is
politically mad to think that this was a
good move we'll get to that in just one
second first if you haven't noticed
already 2020s wild man and the election
race is just getting started well you
know that you need to know everything
from debate and primary updates to the
latest nonsense from the Democratic
candidate it's the best way to stay
informed is to become a daily Y remember
and get comprehensive news and opinion
from us on-demand so we are giving you
20% off only memberships that's correct
20% off all new memberships when you use
promo code at GW 2020 members get our
articles had free access to all of our
live broadcast and show library the full
three hours of the ben shapiro show
select bonus content access to the
mailbag and now my election insight
op-eds plus our new all-access tier it
gets into live online Q&A discussions
with me Andrew Clavin Matt Walsh Michael
moles plus our sites writers and special
guests let us answer your questions and
help you stay one step ahead of the left
if you haven't already download the
daily wear app so you can get push
notifications for breaking news and
special coverage it's a really awesome
feature you're gonna love it again that
is promo code at DW 2024 20% off which
is fantastic so join today stay informed
on all things 2020 we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so then the president goes on the
attack so he spent the first I don't
know two thirds of the speech not going
on attack saying very unifying things
talking about his vision for America and
the Democrats refused to clap then he
goes on the attack and this is the part
where Democrats start getting up and
walking out so president Trump starts
attacking Democrats for the fact that
they want to take over the health care
system and Democrats are very mad about
this they literally start getting up and
walking out which is a bad look and by
the way the Democrats throughout this
speech we're acting childish and
disrespectful it wasn't just Nancy
Pelosi at the end tearing up the
speeches we'll see it was Democrats
throughout acting ridiculous
so reshoot it to leave in Ohio Mar right
during the speech is clip 36 Democrats
were we're actually sitting there and
playing on their phones which by the way
is against House Rules right you're not
supposed to be sitting and playing on
your phone during the State of the Union
address
now the Democrats will say well yeah
well the Republicans were playing with
fidgets spinners during the impeachment
stuff yeah that's true but your case is
that you're the adults in the room
Trump's making the State of the Union
address which is not quite the same as
you know 37 hours of useless testimony
on impeachment but even if it were if
your case is that you're better than the
other side you know it's real dumb
sitting there and looking like you have
nothing but scorn for the process itself
refute it - Leoben ohan Omar you can
actually see it here can we see it
visually wouldn't have to play the whole
clip just fast-forward to the part where
you can see them playing with fidget
spinners if you there it is so you can
see we're to leave in ohan Omar you
know they're they're actually laughing
and yucking it up and and they are and
they are looking at their phone choose
tweeting throughout the speech and she's
tweeting throughout the speech which
again is against house rules if you're
look trying to look like the adults in
the room you don't look like the adults
in the room you look childish and petty
okay so back to President Trump he goes
on attack against the Democrats clip 12
and he talks about his own health care
plans and then he makes a promise that I
think is very dumb which is that he's
never gonna change Medicare and Social
Security basically but then he goes on
real attack against the Democrats says
listen I don't want to steal your health
care plan the Democrats do this is true
I've also made an ironclad pledge to
American families we will always protect
patients with pre-existing conditions
and we will always protect your Medicare
and we will always protect your social
security Oh
but as we work to improve Americans
health care there are those who want to
take away your health care take away
your doctor and abolish private
insurance entirely 132 lawmakers in this
room have endorsed legislation to impose
a socialist takeover of our health care
system wiping out the private health
insurance plans of 180 million very
happy Americans to those watching at
home tonight I want you to know we will
never let socialism destroy American
health care that is 100% true
right there 132 lawmakers who got behind
Bernie's medicare-for-all plan which
does abolish private health care
insurance it does and most Americans the
vast majority of Americans do have
private plans through their employers so
what he's saying there is true and it's
an effective line of attack and Bernie
will get clobbered with it and most
Americans do not want their health plan
disappearing they do not and they are
not interested in having their
gold-plated health care from their
employer replaced with a crap Medicare
program a medicare-for-all program by
the way even seniors have supplemental
Medicare right David they've Medicare
Part D they they generally are buying
supplemental health insurance in order
to supplement their Medicare and then
Trump goes off on illegal immigration
what's hilarious about this particular
portion of the speech is that I'm old
enough to remember when Barack Obama
claims that he didn't want illegal
immigrants covered by Obamacare and Joe
Wilson who is a congressman from I
believe South Carolina yelled out in the
middle of the State of the Union you lie
and this became a massive controversy
huge controversy because Obama said no
I'm not I'm not looking to cover a legal
immigrants I don't I never said that I
don't want to do it now the Democrats
are real open about this I mean there's
an actual question asked at one of the
debates whether their health care plans
would cover illegal immigrants in every
single hand went up and then hilariously
the fact checker is like no they don't
want it to be free Medicare isn't free
you pay taxes that's not the point the
point is if you want a
government-sponsored program to cover
illegal immigrants who are not paying
their fair share of taxes meaning
because they're not legal start paying
taxes but they're not paying income tax
presumably and if they are it's very few
of them if that's the case then you're
seeking to have taxpayers pay for
illegal immigrants health care
really goes off on that is clip 13 over
130 legislators in this chamber have
endorsed legislation that would bankrupt
our nation by providing free
taxpayer-funded health care to millions
of illegal aliens forcing taxpayers to
subsidize free care for anyone in the
world who unlawfully crosses our borders
these proposals would raid the Medicare
benefits of our seniors and that our
seniors depend on while acting as a
powerful lure for illegal immigration
that is what is happening in California
and other states their systems are
totally out of control costing taxpayers
vast and unaffordable amounts of money
if forcing American taxpayers to provide
unlimited free health care to illegal
aliens sounds fair to you then stand
with the radical left but if you believe
that we should defend American patients
and American seniors then stand with me
and pass legislation to prohibit free
government health care for illegal
aliens
okay so again that is gonna be a pretty
telling point and every Democrat has
endorsed the opposite so from did go on
attack here many of the Democrats
started to walk out at this point you
saw Tim Ryan congressman summer I'm
saying I'm walking out now because this
is all wise and it's all terrible and
it's all awful and all the rest of this
but again that is an effective political
attack by President Trump and they're a
bunch of political points that Trump
made and Democrats could even get behind
it like they didn't stand up for the
killing of Baghdady of all Baghdady they
were they were upset when he mentioned
the killing of Qasem Soleimani he
brought to the to the actual State of
the Union the I believe is the the
brother of the or the wife of a sergeant
who was killed by Qasim Soleimani
and then he mentioned some of on his
death and the Democrats were very upset
about all of this again this is just bad
optics for the Democrats which is the
point of the State of the Union is to
create good optics for yourself bad
optics for your political opponents the
best optics for President Trump is the
the Democrats many of them had already
walked out and then Trump did what is
the best TV moment that has ever been
had in the State of the Union addresses
be clip 22 and President Trump brought
the the wife of a
of a member of the Armed Services and
wife and child of a member of the Armed
Services and he reunited the family live
on camera during the State of the Union
which is just great TV
okay yes of course it's gimmicky but
it's not gimmicky when it's when it's
honest and true and fantastic here is
what that looked like
how can you not get trends from that
right I mean it's just fantastic stuff
okay so he finishes up the speech and
this was the most important part of the
speech people are gonna ignore but it
was the most important part of the
speech in his clip 21 so he is he is he
is I'm sorry this clip 23 by the new
numbering so he is talking about the
history of the United States and this is
the great difference between how many
people view America including most
Democrats and how a fraction of the
Democratic Party that has seized control
the Democratic Party he's American I
talked about this extensively on the
show the democratic party the new
democratic party sees America as the
16:19 project America is inherently bad
it's rooted in genocide it's rooted in
racism it's ridden evil it's rooted in
slavery America was born on the back of
human evil and thus everything that has
been good from America has been fruit of
the poisonous tree
president Trump provides a contrary
vision and that is America's been a
pretty damned great place and yes we
haven't always lived up to our original
commitments but the story of America is
this broadening those commitments to
encompass the people they showed up and
expanding those commitments outward to
people who don't even live in this
country free and countenance from
tyranny and slavery freeing people all
over the world creating the greatest
economic engine in the history of
humankind like that is the vision of
America that trump spells out here and
Democrats opposed this so again this is
smart politics here's President Trump
he's implicitly repudiating the
Democrats Howard's in view of the United
States here's President Trump his clip
23 this is the place where the Pilgrims
landed at Plymouth and where Texas
Patriots made their last stand at the
Alamo the beautiful beautiful Alamo the
American nation was carved out of the
vast frontier by the toughest strongest
fiercest and most determined men and
women ever to walk on the face of the
earth
our ancestors braved the unknown tame
the wilderness settled the Wild West
lifted millions from poverty disease and
hunger vanquished
tyranny and fascism assured the world to
new heights of science and medicine laid
down the railroads dug out the canals
raised up the skyscrapers and ladies and
gentlemen our ancestors built the most
exceptional Republic ever to exist in
all of human history
we are making it greater than ever
before the Democrats it for that right
the Democrats they said for that he
gives this really great description what
America has been house built and
Democrats can't stand now maybe they
don't stand because at the very end he
says we're making it greater than ever
so they think they're cheering for Trump
but why exactly can't you cheer for the
fact in America is freaking phenomenal
place it really is and if your campaign
is America sucks and his campaign is
America is great
you're gonna lose you are you're gonna
lose okay so Nancy Pelosi concludes this
really bad night for Democrats by making
it a worst night for Democrats she's
trying to signal to her entire base that
she disapproves of this may remember the
last time around she gave the little
clap and then people like oh look at
that
that Queen slaying she's mocking
president Trump Oh oh ho and then she's
like I wasn't mocking President Peppa
okay now she's like now she's like okay
I'm gonna make this explicit so she's
been waiting the whole speech to get to
this moment because in very produced
fashion she obviously gets up and she
rips up the speech because this is such
trash it's trash here is Nancy Pelosi as
the speech concludes standing up and
tearing the speech in half on camera to
make clear her disdain for the President
of the United States
right so there she is he's tearing up
the speech page by page over and over
right not just once not just twice three
times two is too thick of speech for her
tiny hands to actually grasp and rip
because because she hates Trump so much
because afterward she's that
specifically about why she tore up the
speech right which again is a is a petty
move imagine imagine for just one second
that Paul Ryan during Barack Obama's
State of the Union dress he'd gotten up
at the end ripped it can you imagine the
end it would've been what a racist Paul
Ryan is just he's the President of the
United States you don't rip up the State
of the Union address that he just gave
no matter how much you disagree you have
time to have a democratic response to
this thing later or Republican response
in the case of Paul Ryan why would you
rip up the speech Nancy Pelosi doesn't
slay Queen she's wearing white like the
suffragettes Wow
Slade quit so afterward she has asked
about this and Nancy Pelosi says well I
really wanted to do with something worse
I don't wipe your ass like what exactly
did you want to do with it that was
different
it's just here is Nancy Pelosi
explaining her reaction to ripping up
the speeches clip 31 why did you rip the
speech up madam Speaker that was the
dirtiest thing to do
it was a courteous thing to do because
it should have it should have been
treated much worse which parts of it the
part where he was paying tribute to the
Tuskegee Airmen or the part where he was
talking about killing Somani or the part
where he was reuniting a family or the
part where he was giving a a cancer
ridden conservative icon Rush Limbaugh
the Medal of Freedom in the gallery like
which part of it was the most was the
most offensive to you speaker Pelosi
that's a bad look seriously too bad look
for Democrats makes it look petty makes
it look foolish and that's exactly what
she doesn't want to look like if her
entire pitch is that Donald Trump is
Petty and foolish and ventral then why
would you want to do the exact same
thing if your entire pictures been sober
sent a manatee we are so barium or
sadden or salim right there's been her
entire stick
now she's handing out gold pins at the
Capitol building after signing the
impeachment documents and talking about
saving the Republic while joking with
Bill Lamar like Democrats have no leg to
stand on they're totally undercutting
themselves truly undercutting themselves
their case against Trump was several
fold one president Trump is corrupt and
then you get but then they're saying
like hunter Biden is fine then you get
the Democrats saying - no he's
incompetent and then get the Iowa
caucuses and then you get President
Trump is divisive and petty so your
choice is to hand out gold pens during
impeachment grin broadly and then tear
up his speech after the State of the
Union address like it's dumb politics on
our high-level listen she can do
whatever she wants I'm not one who
believes that we should you know always
respect the institutions and in this way
it's fine I don't care
I really don't what I do think is that
this is moronic I'm not upset at Nancy
Pelosi for doing it I'm actually kind of
happy she did it because it demonstrates
full scale that she is not what she says
she is Nancy Pelosi has pretended for
years that she is the detective right
I've described before I've said
President Trump is not the murderer she
is the coroner and when President Trump
is standing over a dead body and the
dead bodies American politics and all of
the niceties of American politics people
are like well he murdered American
politics and I said before no no no he
just declared it dead American politics
was already in serious trouble and Trump
hasn't fixed it but he declared it dead
Nancy Pelosi has been pretending she's
the detective right she's pretending
that she's the detective but Nancy
Pelosi has been in Washington DC nearly
as long as I've been alive and Nancy
Pelosi is the is the Butler okay she's
not the detective she's not the person
who is tracking down the murderer
she's not the person who's tracking down
all of this who's fixing the problem
she's not the person who's gonna correct
American politics by catching the
murderer and putting them behind bars
she's the Butler
the person who at this is this is a heel
turn for Nancy Pelosi in the WWE lexicon
right
she this is the heel turn she went from
being the suffragette hero to revealing
beneath the pasteboard masks
she's been revealing exactly what she is
which is she is one of the reasons that
American politics has fallen apart and
what she did last night was just her
demonstrating full scale what exactly
she is so good at Nancy Pelosi thanks
for taking off the mask I'm glad we all
got to see that okay time for a very
quick thing I like and then a very quick
thing that I hate so quick thing that I
like I didn't comment on President Trump
in the State of the Union giving the
medal of freedom for rush limbaugh this
is great because it really isn't just
him giving the medal of freedom to Rush
Limbaugh it's really him getting giving
the medal of freedom to all the
Americans that Rush Limbaugh has been
talking to for years Rush has always
been the guy who is speaking to the
Americans who were left out and demeaned
by the mainstream media right that that
really is what Russia is talk radio did
not exist the am band was a nothing
until rush limbaugh reinvigorated the
the the AM Ben but not only did he
reinvigorate the am brand
he gave Republicans and conservatives a
place to get their news that wasn't
dramatically biased against them that
didn't hate them that didn't scorn them
rush limbaugh birds the conservative
commentariat industry without Rush
Limbaugh there wouldn't be the show the
show wouldn't exist without Rush
Limbaugh right shows like this would not
exist without Rush Limbaugh wouldn't be
able to talk to millions of people
without Rush Limbaugh and so Rush being
awarded this a guy from Cape Girardeau
Missouri right which is where he is from
it's kind of a little town near st.
Louis in the the the fact that that Rush
is given a medal of freedom after being
base I mean he'll tell you himself
basically an arrow do well for most of
his young life is like a scout for the
Kansas City Royals is like a gopher for
the Kansas City Royals and then he
started doing like nighttime talk radio
then he was doing local radio in
Sacramento and something becomes this
giant in American conservatism this guy
who represents tens of millions if not
hundreds of millions of Americans in
terms of their viewpoints this guy who
was just diagnosed with stage 4 lung
cancer which unfortunately prognosis is
really not good for stage 4 lung cancer
he's brought to the State of the Union
he's honored he's given the Medal of
Freedom it was a great moment it was
president Trump acknowledging the people
who brought him to the presidency his
who had been forgotten
and scorn and distained by the media the
same people that Russia's been talking
to for years I thought it was a
wonderful moment the Democrats of course
are very upset about this the same
Democrats who were very happy with Teddy
Kennedy a man who left a woman to drown
under a frickin bridge right they're
happy when he got the Medal of Freedom
from Barack Obama they were very very
upset that Rush Limbaugh should get the
Medal of Freedom now Russia should
presumably leave woman to die maybe
maybe that would get them the Medal of
Freedom in any democratic Alexa Kahn
it's pretty amazing but in any case he
was given the Medal of Freedom last
night it was a pretty great moment in
recognition of all that you have done
for our nation the millions of people a
day that you speak to and that you
inspire and all of the incredible work
that you have done for charity I am
proud to announce tonight that you will
be receiving our country's highest
civilian honor the Presidential Medal of
Freedom
I will now ask the First Lady of the
United States to present you with the
honor please
[Applause]
it's a pretty fantastic moment brush
obviously you know he was having trouble
hearing which is pretty obvious in
echoey rooms he's had ear problems yet
he has cochlear implants he's had that
for years the the obviously emotional
and in terraces as should be I mean it's
the fact that the media have have been
what they are is the reason why Rush
Limbaugh was important to the country
and is important to the country and will
continue to be important to the country
he's had an impact on generations that
was a wonderful wonderful moment and
good for the President of the United
States for paying tribute to an iconic
conservative who has shaped so many
minds and hearts over the course of
years okay time for a quick thing that I
hate so as I say the Democratic response
to the State of the Union is
over-the-top and insane like insane
here's a wildly popular State of the
Union it's best to Trump is the best
Trump has been if he if he can keep this
up which I doubt because within 12 hours
he'll be tweeting something dumb but if
he could keep this up he would win you
know I mean he walloped the Democrats if
this is where if this worked full-time
Trump as opposed to very part-time Trump
the Democrats would be in a lot more
serious trouble even than they are well
the Democrats were very upset members of
the media were super upset about all of
this Jonathan alter from Newsweek he
compared a president from State of the
Union to Nazi propagandist Joseph
Goebbels okay just a quick point Joseph
Goebbels was was like a Nazi and who's
propagandizing on behalf of the genocide
of Jews you might want to stay away from
the gurbles
comparisons when you're talking about
the President of the United States given
what was by all accounts a fairly
measured and generally well precedented
State of the Union address even if you
don't believe that he was spitting out
the facts the way Huffington Post wanted
him to spit out the facts even if you
believe that that he was quote-unquote
lying the way the Democrats keep
claiming
that's something that presidents do
during the state of Union all the time
it's a political speech of course to
comparison Joseph garbles is patently
insane but this is what the media has
done Trump Trump has driven them out of
their gourds the gourd has a hole in it
in their brains are falling out like
they're there they're just there they're
crazy they've lost it here's Jonathan
alter losing it he is a master marketer
and and he understands as Mark Twain
said that a lie gets halfway around the
world
for the truth can get its boots on and
it's one thing to lie in in tweets and
then you know there people are absorbing
them at different times and go through
the news cycle it can be but when you're
doing it repeatedly in real time and
part of it is
gurbles the big lie the big lie
really the big it's it's Goebbels the
big lie seriously come on yang come on
and then I did love Rasheeda to lieb's
reaction so she walked out of the State
of the Union why did she walk out of the
State of the Union she walked out
because the president mentioned Brett
Kavanaugh which was there you can't
mention Brett Kavanaugh according to
Rasheeda to lead now you sure to mention
Hamas that would have pleased her more
because Rasheeda totally Blake's come
off more than she likes Brett Kavanaugh
which says something about the
Democratic Party here she was with
Rachel Maddow tut-tutting the State of
the Union you were among the several
Democratic lawmakers who actually walked
out of the president's speech before it
was done tonight tell me about that
decision and what was the tipping point
for you well I think you know the even
the mention of Brett Kavanaugh for me is
a trigger
just as a woman in America the fact that
he you know rightfully was accused and
and having an incredibly strong woman
come before the public in the world and
tell her story of sexual assault by this
person that was appointed to the Supreme
Court is just alone that I couldn't
stand still and not doing anything about
it is guys she hadn't planned anything
hey honestly I never thought I would say
this I'm wrong for the decorum of AOC
seriously like at least AOC did what she
should do she said listen I'm not gonna
show up and I'm gonna go home I'm gonna
I'm gonna cook something in the instant
pot mix a few drinks and do some
instagramming like at least that's
respectful enough to the process of
saying listen I know that I'm not gonna
like what I hear but I'm not gonna stage
this walkout and do this very childish
thing where I go there and rip things up
and play on my phone well the whole
thing is going on I'm just not gonna be
there props to AOC seriously like that's
an actual quasi mature thing to do it's
so not like perfectly mature but it's
quasi mature I was like what's not
mature is playing on your phone while
you're yucking it up with Aloha and Omar
and then you leave because Brett
Kavanaugh was mentioned and go to hell
seriously it's just ridiculous it's
ridiculous the whole thing is ridiculous
but you know what when they show them
when they show you who they are believe
them
right
they're fond of quoting the Maya Angelou
quote alright when when we're Sheena
talib shows you who she is believe her
okay so this is who the Democrats are
they're immature and they're and if
their case is that they are the adults
in the room they did not prove it last
night where they looked incredibly
childish and Trump looked very very
presidential
now again can Trump stay there let's see
what time is it like probably not and
when I say probably I mean no because
the president was then on Twitter
immediately after the speech just
retweeting all these anti Nancy Pelosi
memes just let it sit mr. president
seriously just wanted said but what did
last night prove it proved that if
anything even if you say that Trump's
gonna go back to being Trump which he
will even if you say that what what what
you really saw last night is that the
Democrats are not a difference in kind
they are just socialists who are also
children so if they're ripping Trump is
that he's a thin-skinned orange man bad
child you didn't prove that you guys
were anything but thin-skinned and
childish and ridiculous last night when
you walk out of speeches early before we
could pay tribute to members of the
military tear up speeches refused to use
the traditional honorifics play with
your phone during the State of the Union
address you made yourself look like
asses and you know what good because the
American people should see that the
choice in 2020 there is no quote-unquote
dignified candidate on the ballot you're
just gonna have a choice between
socialists who are undignified and
somebody who's not a socialist and who
kind of likes America who is who is not
supremely dignified alrighty we'll be
back here later today with two
additional hours of content or
alternatively we'll be back here
tomorrow go subscribe right now daily
wire when you do use DW 20/20 get 20%
off or we will see you here tomorrow I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the bench Bureau
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel I douse key
technical producer Austin Stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Camino hair and makeup is by
Anika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 on the Matt Walsh oh we're
not just discussing politics we're
talking culture faith family all of the
things that are really important to you
so come join the conversation
[Music]
you